justin what have you been up to man i
understand you're over in uh dubai right
now
yep i'm over in dubai with the tates
we're doing a war room event so we got
about 20 guys here learning about all
three of those things the whole money
muscles game thing um getting frame
right with women we actually
um the guy running the event is a very
dear friend of ours he's actually taken
all of them to the tailors
going really really really deep into
style i've learned a lot from them
actually myself
just kind of one of the benefits of
being in this group so
um the guys are learning a lot i'm
learning a lot
we're making money so it's good they
have um
do they have a uh a lot of like asian
tailors over there like do they
actually cut the suits in the shirts
there or they take the measurements send
them over to hong kong and then ship
them over to you in the mail
no actually they have a whole team of
guys they're indian
and i had i have three suits and one
jacket made in four days
so my first day i went in we picked the
colors and we ended up picking the
piping and everything so my signature
and everything got put in this
particular suit this one was made the
other day um so day one we picked the
colors they cut it once came back cut it
again final cuts and uh they had they
had four suits out the door or four
jackets and three pairs of pants out the
door for me in four days
incredibly man it's pretty quick i use
an outfit here i've talked about this
before it's called maxwells and they do
kind of like a north american tour they
measure you up but uh
they usually rent out like a conference
room in a hotel uh you know they take
your measurements uh send them over to
hong kong they cut it up and they send
you the stuff in the mail so it's um
it's something i recommend guys do like
it makes a big big difference actually
since we're on the topic there is a
there's a picture here that um i got
from you earlier today that i wanted to
kind of kick this off on because this
kind of like
exemplifies the difference between
poorly fitting clothing on a generally
fat body versus you know something
that's cut to fit properly so this is an
older picture of you like how old are
you here
probably 24
24 and uh you got you know like the
belly hanging over the belt it's one of
those off the rack shirts
versus versus what you got right now
like that's a far better look yeah
absolutely like there's actually no
question about it like you've got
you've got a far better or far higher
value
perceived value anyway you know by the
world by women by other guys as well
when you wear clothes that fit properly
and um you know compliment your physique
versus something that's just like pulled
off the rack and it's
you know you look like a refrigerator
basically right square
yeah absolutely you know even in fact
before i was buying custom custom suits
i would even if i bought a 200 suit from
somewhere like a um
i don't know like dillard's
going to get that suit cut tightly
fitting to me made all the difference in
the world
you know so it i
i really believe even a younger guy
could could make a huge difference in
his wardrobe just by getting something
cut
very very closely to him
even if he bought it just off the rack
and hadn't had it done the right way so
um i get them i get them cut custom now
it's a big difference yeah then you get
pretty much anything cut to be honest
with you man i i i got this uh
mclaren um zip up kind of like sweater
just over the holidays it was way too
bad you know guys that buy these cars
are generally older guys have you know
put on some poundage i just brought it
in do charge me like 30 35 bucks to get
it taken in a bit you know kind of up
here in the sleeves everything fits
better when you do things that way it's
it's dude it's like guys watching don't
discount properly fitting clothes like
make sure that you that you hold out to
the public something that looks good on
your physique and definitely don't walk
around fat
you